[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROB CRAFT: I have
three demos I can show.
I can slot in an additional six
slides, if you would prefer.
I'm betting if you
came to a machine
learning session this
late, demos are probably
where the action is at.
If anyone disagrees, feel
free to swig beer right now.
There's got to be a drinking
game involved, guys.
There has to be.
OK.
My name is Rob Craft.
I'm responsible for the
machine learning products
for Google Cloud Platform
on the product side.
I'm going to try to spend
the next hour with you guys
mostly with me talking.
Unfortunately, that's kind of
the way this stage thing works.
But I'm going to try to do my
best to honor the shot clock--
because they're conveniently
giving me a nice, big,
blinking clock at
the bottom here--
with 10 to 12 minutes at
the end for questions.
We do have microphones set up.
And then, there's
always the option
to dogpile the stage
at the end, which
seems to be what most
people choose to do.
I may or may not grab
a beer and nod vaguely.
So questions publicly would
receive better responses.
Does that sound cool?
All right.
So we saw this guy today.
He does good talk, doesn't he?
He should do this for a living.
Turns out, a lot of
what we're trying
to do with machine
learning is public now.
So it seems new and inviting
to a lot of people that perhaps
don't have a long history
with machine learning,
or artificial intelligence.
Depending on what
university you went through,
it's either called AI or ML.
For some folks that have
been practicing in the space,
this has been the
normal reaction
when you tell people you have
an advanced degree in machine
learning or AI.
People do this face.
You ready?
Yeah.
How's that going?
You have job?
But you have job?
OK, all right.
That's good.
So you're writing code, or?
So it's come out
of the back end.
Remember Deep Blue?
And winning chess matches,
and Jeopardy, and--
that was all brute force.
It was a dictionary-based
system that
had some heuristics
on the back side.
The Jeopardy system was a
natural language-based system
that brute-forced
on the BI system.
So at the end of the day,
those were great demo cases
to get people excited about a
machine that can look and feel
like it's thinking, or
that it's doing cognition,
or that it's doing
predictions on things.
Largely, these things went
dark immediately after that.
And then everyone started
working on it anyway.
So pharmaceuticals,
trading applications
for high speed
trading, people that
do protein folding modeling,
drug interactions, oil gas
field exploration,
seismic study, climate
modeling-- you get the idea.
These things have
been largely the realm
of very expensive, very
boutique, and very quiet
innovation.
About a year ago,
Google published
something called TensorFlow
from our Brain team, which
is an open source, deep and
wide set of frameworks that
allow you to create
your own set of systems
with exactly the same code
that we use internally.
The good news there is
it's pretty well tested,
it's supported by some
wicked smart people.
The bad news is you're
still writing machine code.
So what I thought
might be interesting,
and I was foolish enough to be
close enough to being correct
that they gave me
the job, was, why
don't we try to automate
all the tough stuff?
And leave the interesting stuff,
which normally isn't tough.
How many people in the room
used to write assembly code
for a living?
God, and you're still
relatively sane.
At least you're
all wearing pants,
which is kind of the
bar at this point.
It is-- it was
really hard, right?
You kind of care how
the system worked.
But the line of code you
wrote was hand-crafted.
It was a thing of beauty.
It worked at super
high performance,
and you understood
everything about it.
We're largely still at
that level for most machine
learning models
that people create.
They handcraft it, they
understand it deeply,
or they wish they did.
In the case of neural networks.
And I'll explain a little
bit why that's harder
than it was with wide models.
But at the end of the day,
it isn't a scalable system
where you can say, OK,
I'll do the initial thing,
but I have 50 people who
can probably take this
to the next level of scale.
Everybody's writing that
hand-crafted level thing.
So we're at the year
one, you can think of,
having large scale access
to human producible machine
learning code, which
is quite good, not OK--
not a simple linear regression
model and not time series data
based stuff.
So this is kind of the
beginning of the cycle
that Eric called out.
And by the way, this
was from Next 16,
which was about a year ago.
It was held in a really cool
facility in San Francisco
with about one fourth of the
people that came this year.
And it's not about me.
I get it.
But the top five subscribed
sessions at this Next event
were all machine
learning relative,
which indicates that we're doing
a very poor job explaining what
machine learning is
because everyone's
coming to the sessions.
So let's get ourselves
out of a job pretty quick.
I do this one mostly
for the meta experience.
So for those of you that
have a machine learning
pipeline already figured out
in a system that already uses
this stuff, you're
like OK, yeah,
we've already gone
through this stage.
I would wager most
of us in the room
have heard enough about machine
learning that they think they
should do something with it.
But they don't
necessarily understand
how to understand discretely.
Should I be building
my own models
and hiring a team that
knows how to do this stuff,
and hand crafting, and dealing
with open source tool sets,
and a lot of other
really hard work?
Or should I go with
a black box system
that I've seen come into the
market in the last 18 months,
something that solves
translation, that understands
spoken word, that can
identify five people wearing
weird costumes, smiling,
and two of them are happy,
and three of them are sad--
those sorts of things.
So this is meant to try
to guide us through it.
Don't worry.
It did say "pop quiz" in order
to get everyone's attention
because most people are
overachievers if they're coming
to a machine learning session at
6:40 at night, as we discussed.
But it's both open
book and open answer.
So let me quickly flip through.
And I even started
drinking myself,
if you can tell by
the check marks.
A couple of things.
The first one that--
let me just walk through
one or two of these,
and you guys will
kind of get the idea.
Detect-- B2B is business to
business-- company products
in users' living room photos.
OK.
So that probably
means you can't run
on a public backbone
based system
because that might be creepy--
but not creepy like Santa
Claus, creepy like NSA.
So let's not be creepy about it.
Let's have a fully
established system
that's built on a
trusted environment
that you have full control on.
And you will have full
control of the features
that you develop.
In this case, you would use ML
Engine to build your own model.
And you would
provision that model
to perhaps even run
on the smart TV.
Or you would have it run on
the remote control in the room.
We'll provision upwards of
six billion new addressable
devices.
For those of you that have been
trolling the new IOT stage,
you get the idea that
we're going to have
a lot of devices coming online.
More and more of
these devices will
have sufficient
compute capability
to do predictions locally.
Several will have sufficient
compute capability
to do training locally.
And the science behind this
will advance in the next year
to 18 months for sure from us
to allow a supervisory service
to declare when training should
occur, where, and with what
model.
So this gets really, really
interesting to enable
device side stuff.
So I wanted to call this one
out first that it's in ML Engine
today.
ML Engine today is
distributed TensorFlow
with a whole lot
of magic behind it,
automating a lot of the
system provisioning, making
it a managed service.
But over time, it will turn
into much more of a drag drop
exercise, a guided experience
like data that looks like this.
Here's the four algorithms
you should start with.
Here's the pre-processing
pipeline we recommend.
And here's the
overall tuning that we
recommend on your neural
network when you're
through your first trial.
So you get the idea
of these things
become increasingly
more valuable and faster
to use over time.
"Over time" used to mean
years and years and years.
It's moving so much faster.
And I'll talk about translation
in a moment as another example.
So let's maybe offer
a scandalous view
on the state of silicone
in the marketplace.
I spoke at our partner
conference on Tuesday night,
and NVIDIA was in the room.
They literally high fived
when I came to this slide.
And I think they were smoking
cigars and putting orders
in for Maseratis.
But the short
version of the story
is, holy mother, is GPUs
turning into a core facility
to drastically
improve the latency--
shortening it-- the time
to train-- shortening it--
and the amount of
predictions which
can handle per unit of watt.
At Google, we typically think on
feature representation per watt
involved in our data center.
And that's how we
optimize our workloads is
efficiency is great.
Efficiency writ
large looks like,
are we powering the
right facilities
with the right capabilities?
In this case, though,
the idea behind this
is largely the CPU
market has stabilized.
"Flat" was a harsh word,
according to my friends
at Intel I had lunch with.
But what it might mean
is relative to compute
through CPU, compute through
GPUs is explosively growing.
And it's growing in particular
in one area almost uniquely,
and that is machine
learning focused.
This chart, if you were to
look at how Google manages
its own data center
systems, would largely
represent what we think
of as continuing services
that we want to increase
efficiencies with over time.
But growth increases.
So roughly, you
reach a steady state
after you get to a few million
compute cores involved.
When you start adding
GPUs to the mix,
the math changes pretty
quickly because server density
is really hard.
You can't pack 400 GPUs in
one 42U rack space, right?
The floor melts.
So you have to have some
sort of density metric
to figure these things out.
Turns out GPUs are
relatively power hungry.
That's our problem to solve,
in our view, in this world.
Or it can be your
problem to solve
if you want to create your own
ecosystem around this on prem
or through your own
host or a partner.
What I will promise
you, since I've
gone through the
exercise for Google,
you will under spec and
underestimate the price
of your spec for the GPUs
that you want to buy.
Surprisingly enough, with
98% share in the market,
NVIDIA isn't going to
cut you too terribly
good a deal unless you buy a
whole bunch of these things.
So my argument for
why you're here
is, why wouldn't you let someone
else worry about the hard stuff
on provisioning these things
with super high density?
And for those of you that
have been following the Google
space for a while, there's
one thing not on this chart.
I call out the word CPU
is there, GPU is there.
There's another
three letter acronym.
Anyone want to win a t-shirt?
Too many drinks.
TPU, Tensor Processing Unit.
Get that guy another
sweater vest.
So the tensor processing units
are dedicated for machine
learning purposes only.
You can think of CUDA
cores and other GPUs
as really dumb, really
simple, but really a lot
of core compute that's really
great for parallelizable
things.
TPUs is a family of things
that Google's been investing in
for several years to
drastically lower the watt curve
but drastically increase the
slope of the usage curve.
So we'll be talking more
about that over the years
because nobody can keep a
secret in the silicon business.
I'm sure we'll be talking
public about these things
over the next while.
The while could be 18 months
if we're particularly lucky.
It could be shorter
if we're less lucky.
But the general idea here
is up and to the right
for all usage for machine
learning inside of Google.
And we think that's a
corollary for certain segments
of customers outside
of Google as well.
So our math on this was as this
curve goes up and to the right,
why don't we invest in
tools and technologies
to make it simpler to use
at larger and larger scale?
That set of tools,
I'm very happy to say,
is exactly what we're
going to offer you
guys, not any simpler version
or any longer range version.
You've heard us talk about
spanner a lot today--
really cool stuff.
Been used for years
inside of Google.
Everyone familiar
with MapReduce?
Paper written almost a
decade ago and no longer
in use at Google
because it doesn't
scale to what we need it to.
That was 10 years.
Then we went to about six
years, then to three years.
The TensorFlow system
was written and used
immediately inside of Google
and made available the same day.
So we've shortened
the innovation cycle
for what we think
we need internally
for the next stage of things
were offered immediately,
in the case of TensorFlow, as
it's still really hard to do
but it's really, really good.
And it took me 14 months--
I'm sorry a little slow--
to turn this into a
generalizable solution
set that's called ML Engine.
So we'll talk about these
things more in depth.
But I want to get
across the cycle that's
meant to make this curve pay
off in revenue for all of us.
This is one of the proof points.
We're a search business.
Some of you guys have used us.
Hopefully, you found your
way to Mosconi using Maps.
It's a pretty good product.
In this case, this is based
on a blog article we put out
against RankBrain, which is
an internal machine learning
system we use to optimize
intent fulfillment
and to get away
from writing rules.
So my quick anecdote
for search at Google
is on words of nine
years ago at this point,
we got out of the
rules business.
Everyone in this room probably
writes rules for a living
if you write code.
If this, then that.
Those are rules.
The following
conditions are met,
the following thing
should execute.
The store procedure sees
this, the store procedure
writes that.
Those are all
rules-based systems.
What if you were
able to declare,
through a statistical
model, here's
what good looks like and
the confidence that good
is this thing.
And why doesn't the system
then determine on its own
how it should execute to
get to that good thing?
That's largely what a
predictive-based system
tries to get to.
And happily, when we gave
up on writing rules inside
of Google for our search engine,
we had several million rules.
If I type the word
"giants" and "baseball,"
I get a result. If I
type "baseball" and then
"giants," in many cases,
I got a different result.
And part of that
was the way that it
assumed my language type
affected what my meaning was.
Part of it was just because
someone wrote a rule
and it didn't debug to the same
condition when we executed it.
With the condition that
we we're in today, mapping
those three million
rules into the number
of intents that people have,
the number of intents people
actually want is
much, much smaller,
drastically reducing the support
mechanism required to prove
that we're fulfilling intent.
And it's much easier for
the bench code and test code
to make sure these things work.
So does that logic make sense?
For those of you
considering, why
should use machine learning?
The short answer is if you
have some gnarly code that you
no longer want to support,
and it changes a lot then
what the business
rules are for it,
and you're lucky enough to
have a decent amount of data
to understand what is a good
outcome and a bad outcome
for a particular
business process,
it's a great candidate for
a machine learning solution.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about some
of the verticalized things.
I'll do two further examples
inside of the photo space.
White text on a white background
is always a great idea,
apparently.
Sorry about that.
And yes, the lower right
is indeed a glacier.
So in the case of
Photos, everyone
used Google Photos at
some time, played with it?
It got drastically
better about a year ago.
Everyone was like, oh, that's
actually surprisingly nice.
What we were doing was
labeling all the imagery
behind the scenes
and saying, here's
all the pictures of Mary.
We're going to tag it with Mary.
Here's all the pictures
of birthday parties.
And now you can type in, show
me birthday party pictures
of Mary.
And it shows it to you.
And you're like, well,
of course it does.
I expect that.
A year ago, this
was black magic.
Getting to the place where
you can do that in video
and at scale across thousands
and thousands of videos
against things that
you haven't seen before
and thus don't have
labels for, that's
the challenge in front of us.
And that's the opportunity
in front of you guys
if you want to
extend the systems.
So all these core
frameworks that
were involved in creating
photos and other things now
are wrapped into a
service called Vision API.
And I'll talk about
that in a little while.
But the core of Vision API is it
provides labels with confidence
that you can then write client
side code on without writing
all the thousands and millions
of lines of hard end stuff
to be able to get
the core systems.
There were many PhDs in
the space 20 years ago.
You saw [INAUDIBLE] shaking
your head saying, man, we
have video now.
I wish we had video at
Stanford figured out.
That is really,
really hard because,
as we hopefully have known if
we've ever-- remember DVDs?
If you froze a DVD and
you saw the picture,
it looked really bad.
You don't remember the
movie looking that bad.
But when you freeze frame
a DVD image, it looks bad.
Well, at 30 frames
a second, your eye
handles all the
badness on the imagery,
which is how they can get
away with three megabit
kind of imagery per second.
Well, video at 30
frames a second,
interpreted as if it
were a standalone scene,
doesn't do very well at all.
It turns out you need a whole
different set of techniques
to go after video
systems than you
do straight 2D vision systems.
So more to come there.
This is my ironic slide.
10% of Google Gmail is Gmail
talking to Gmail at this point.
We're working hard to try
to get this higher as we go.
What this does is
solved a UI problem.
Thousands of hours
of PhD time spent
tuning a machine
learning model, all
intended to solve the
fact that your thumbs are
bigger than your
keyboard on your phone.
Literally, it was to
save the 10 seconds
and you fat fingering
your response
and not paying attention
to someone at the table
while you do this.
Because we're all going
to be having dinner later,
and you're probably all going
to be texting someone while
you're doing it.
And wouldn't be nice if at
the bottom it could just say,
I don't know.
But I'll get right back to you.
Because it was a question
asked about something.
And it's a person
that you've talked
with that you've responded to
in a personal context before.
So you take the trouble to say,
I'll get right back to you.
If it's someone
that you normally
interact with on a
very casual style,
it'll say, no idea, dude.
The ability to do that is
quite difficult to get right.
And when you get it wrong,
boy, does it feel wrong.
More and more of the time,
those little three answers
at the bottom of the GIF
that you guys are seeing
is turning into something that,
in-context, actually does not
cause you to do
a context switch.
You're able to continue
the conversation.
You'll glance down, you'll
give a quick scan of the mail,
you look at the bottom.
One of those three will
probably be close enough.
And then you move on
with the rest of your day
and you get to keep your
attention on what you're on.
It was a UX problem
because the five inch
screen and thumbs and
math and machine learning
was a solution here.
So two things are interesting.
One is the system
is able to automate
its own behaviors-- in this
case, response to mails.
And the second piece is it's
improved so fast so quickly.
So this was-- gosh, I think
less than 15 months old
at this point.
And for my purposes, over
70% of the time at least,
I'm picking one of the
three at the bottom,
whether it's my boss or
whether it's my wife.
And you could argue
that's the same person.
OK.
Google Translate with
neural machine translation.
This was a broad set
of announcements we did
all the way back in November.
Everyone in the room
used Google Translation?
Thank you.
My mortgage thanks you.
My family thanks you.
So we used to be pretty good at
this whole translation stuff.
And what it requires is a pretty
big system, dozens and dozens
of languages, variants on
languages, colloquialisms,
localizations, mistakes
handling, all that good stuff,
all baked in a very, very
strong team in Google Research.
About six months ago, they
picked up the challenge
to start using some TensorFlow
systems and some accelerating
hardware so they can do
massive amounts of training
on data set which before
was relatively opaque.
Because they do billions of
characters of translations
a day, working through that
backlog entirely-- gosh,
why would you bother because
it only gets 1% or 2% better
on a heuristic system if you
go all the way soup to nuts?
Then they applied
a neural network
based system on top of it with
some help from the brain team.
We have 85% lower error rates on
our eight top languages today.
We're better than
human translations
at two of those top
eight language pairs.
And we're now able to
translate languages
that we don't speak
because the neural network
between languages that are
relatively close on family
basis translate roughly the
same between language pairs.
Really exciting space.
So take a look if you
want to read after.
Or if you're able
to multitask, you
can read the blog entry
that we did on it today.
We rolled out to eight
languages initially,
which covers about 35% of the
spoken or written language.
I think we rolled out
another three days ago--
Vietnamese and a
couple of others.
Know that Mandarin
is our arch nemesis.
It is super hard.
Mandarin speakers
think Mandarin is hard.
If you give them enough
drink, they'll tell you that.
We hope to largely solve for
some of these canonically
difficult languages within
the next couple of years
to human standard
of translation.
At better than human standard,
it sounds like that's amazing.
It's still not quite
perfect because the way
you would phrase it might be
phraseologically different
whether you're speaking
casually or whether you're
speaking formally.
Because one of my
top feature areas
have asked for people
to use our translation
service for business use because
this is a full service that you
can use rather than just
for websites at Google is,
I would like to have a
casual translation service.
I would like one for medical.
I would like the
system to understand
that CAGR in French--
Combined Avenue Growth Rate--
is CAGR.
They don't translate it.
They flip between languages
in professional settings
many times.
Some of you whose English
isn't the first language
probably do this yourselves.
You'll be speaking to
the family at home.
All of a sudden pops out
three or four words in English
just because it's easier
or more convenient,
or the concept is
cleaner for you.
Getting that kind of
intermix is something
we're not quite good
enough yet in my view.
We're actively working on it.
OK.
Everyone in the
room heard of chess?
Some people in the room are
probably pretty decent at it.
If you've got a computer
science, math background,
it tends to have
some correlation
to chess capability.
Anyone in the room
any good at Go?
Oh, there's some profess to
actually being good at Go,
not playing Go.
That's awesome.
It turned out that we had
estimates of 20 to 30 years
before a machine
learning system would
be able to beat a
relatively good Go player.
And about eight months'
worth of work, the DeepMind,
which is an Alphabet company
that's not part of core Google,
but obviously, we talk--
were able to write
a system that was
able to beat number three in
the world in an enormous stadium
full of people.
And boy, was that
earth shattering
for people in the Go space.
Next challenge that we're
trying to pick up in this area
is strategic games.
Anyone know why so many people
in machine learning and AI
spend time trying
to solve games?
Can anyone describe
in one sentence
why you enjoy playing cards?
And the answer is
you probably can't.
You would say things
like, because it's fun,
or I like being
with friends, or I
like doing the math in my
head if I'm a particular card
shark about it.
But you would choose a
different sentence, which means
it's a hard cognition problem.
The way that you learn is a
way that someone else doesn't
learn, or they learn
through a different vector.
That's why there's different
teaching styles in schools.
So at the end of the
day, machine learning
is one of the techniques
in the larger universe
of artificial intelligence.
But if you can teach
a game to a computer,
you are so much closer to
having the computer being
able to cognate like a
person and solve problems
in a way that's
relatable to a human.
Because we're not
ever, in this space,
trying to solve a machine being
able to talk to a machine.
That exists.
It's having a person
be able to tersely
and completely explain something
to a computer and the reverse.
And I don't have it
in this slide deck,
but we have self captioning,
which is amazing.
We have a picture of a small
child holding a stuffed animal.
And the self caption created
by the machine learning system
is "a cute child holding
her stuffed animal."
What would you say
in that picture would
be exactly the same words.
They got that one right.
There's some wildly
hilarious ones,
which are absolutely not
right, which typically I
don't put on a slide.
But you get the idea.
It's like, when you
get that one moment.
Normally at work,
like when you have
code that compiles clean the
first time, you drop the mic.
You're like, I'm
getting a coffee, right?
I am the best
coder in the world.
As a machine
scientist, once you get
that one thing that's at
94% accuracy, you're like,
don't touch it.
Save, save, save.
You want to save over and over
like you just beat the boss
at the end of the level.
That tells you we're a little
bit early in the ability
to debug and
understand causation
for some of the things we do.
But Alpha Go is doing
some really significantly
interesting things about
true AI and the attempt
to solve how things think.
They're using a lot of advanced
techniques in machine learning.
Powering these systems
is Google Cloud,
it may not surprise
you to learn.
It also would not surprise you
to learn that CPUs and GPUs
weren't up to the task.
And they used some
specialized silicone
to make this stuff make
sense in near real time.
So let me get really practical.
I talked a little
bit about wattage.
At the end of the day,
Google is a power buyer.
We buy lots of power.
We buy hundreds of thousands
of cores of compute
every single quarter.
We buy tens of
thousands per week.
We deploy thousands
of racks per day.
You get the idea.
We're deploying a new data
center a month this year
alone for Google Cloud.
We kind of are in
the power business.
At the end of the day, we've
spent many, many, many years
increasing our
power efficiencies.
And it's handcrafted
based on, OK,
does this rack have a lot
of compute cores in it?
Well, then the fan
should face this way.
If this one has a lot
of disks, are they
SSD or are they spinning disks?
OK.
Well, then you want to
balance the air flow this way.
And over time, you work the
air flow through the room.
You shift how you
do power coupling.
You have higher and higher
efficiency power distribution
units, and leads to better
networking performance.
You get the idea
that at some point,
it doesn't make sense
to cool a data center.
Most data centers are
room temperature today.
Well, that was where you
see ML Control on the left.
We dropped it 40% in
about three months,
which resulted in a 15%
lower budget requirement
for all Google data centers.
Holy crap.
You should have seen the
faces on the data center team.
They were so sad because
they thought they had it.
It's like they'd
dropped the mic.
We're the best people in the--
wait a minute.
In three months, we
see a 40% reduction
on cooling bill, which results
in 15% lower power draw.
And power draw is the
largest capital expenditure
you'll probably see in
Google's 10K report.
So this is one of
the opportunities
that we see might be a
repeatable thing if we can
genericize the rule base to say,
show me what your data center
layout looks like.
Give me a description in UML for
what is in each of the racks.
And we will tell you how to work
the power flow and the power
distribution in
your data center,
resulting in significant
and real savings
and for your own data centers.
Maybe not to the
scale of Google,
because we do such interesting
things that are custom.
But what if HP had
this capability
to include in the box?
You buy the box, you
get the cooling savings.
These sorts of things become
natural complimentary things.
And this work in three months.
Normally a rack layout
change for a Google center
takes 18 to 24 months
of design time.
We work intensely with
providers of the racks.
What thickness steel,
where does the fan
go, what's the RPM, what's
the noise allowment?
Are we going to do
natural cooling or are
we going to put it somewhere
far north, where we
can bring in environmental air?
All those sorts of
things factor in.
This was largely free.
It was three people for
less than three months.
Two months were them learning
what a data center did
because they're mathematicians.
So let's get right
to the basics.
This is why I get head
count in resources.
90% of the world's
data doesn't say, hey,
I'm a picture of Rob's
three-year-old girl
at a birthday party.
It just has, picture.
And as we discovered,
turns out most people
on the internet don't
actually label things
with what they actually are.
Sometimes they're
very bad things
and you don't want them
in your data center.
Sometimes they're already
And how do you just
delete the things
that shouldn't be
in the data center
in order to preserve the
value of the larger things?
So all these things
originate from the base point
that we're trying to
drive unstructured data
into structured understanding.
Once it's structured
data against it,
then you can provide
value on top of it.
That's largely what
Google's been doing
since Google's been created.
That's why we started
with all the ML APIS first
before I got the ML
Engine out the door.
It was to largely try to
solve for this problem space.
There's four things
that matter, Rob says.
There's three
things on the slide.
Data and algorithms.
The data side we can
provide, you can provide,
or you can buy
from someone else.
But data exists.
Getting clean data
is super hard.
75% of the workload for
machine learning scientists
is doing data modeling.
25% of the time, they
get to play with math.
By the way, they're
mathematicians.
You want to see a grumpy person?
Ask a mathematician
to do database stuff.
They really don't like doing it.
So don't make them do that.
So data.
Next piece is algorithms.
The algorithm space has been
around for 40 plus years.
Many of these algorithms
you get your PhD
when you improve the
algorithm's efficiency by 2%,
or it requires 30% less
computational complexity,
or it's been [INAUDIBLE]
for long running pipeline.
You get the idea that a lot
of these are small tunes.
But overall, the
techniques around them
are enormously advancing.
Neural machine translation
is a great example of that.
That art didn't exist
two or three years ago,
and didn't originate from
research universities
because the corpus
required to do
that work was beyond what a
grad student was going to get
a grant to go to work on.
So then you need
commercial entities.
And we made a decision when we
started this journey that we
were going to open everything.
So I'm going to show
you a natural language
example in just a moment.
It's based on an open
source implementation
that we released.
Anyone know the name of the open
source natural language system
that's coming from Google?
Brace for a weird story.
Parsey McParseface.
Yes, there are British
people involved.
The Brits held a
competition on what
they should name the new
boat that the British
Navy was going to christen.
The name of the boat that
won through popular demand
in Britain was Boaty McBoatface.
So some Brits were
on the brain team
and thought it would be
funny to say, why don't we
christen this with
Parsey McParseface
because they're
parsing language.
So that will save you maybe
a free beer at a party.
The last point on the
right is insights.
Insights are the
predictions that you
can connect to your rest
of your business processes.
And the fourth thing is
the people in the seats.
It's you guys.
These things have to be created.
Someone has to write the code.
Someone has to test the systems,
get it sold, get it deployed.
None of this matters about what
Google is releasing externally
until someone uses it.
So happily, we've
got 10,000 people.
And this turns out to be
something pretty interesting
for a lot of them.
I'll quickly try to describe
what a neural network does.
My huge apologies to the experts
in the room that may find this
well oversimplified to the
point of offensiveness.
But it's largely true.
Have a drink of beer.
So on the input side
and the output side,
you'll see two rough squares
there with little circles.
Think of the square as a layer.
And each layer as it forms
turns into a network of things.
That's why it's called
a neural network.
Each of the algorithms you
can think of as a neuron.
And neuron, when the condition
is met, fires an impulse.
That impulse is a
signal that your brain
uses to decide something.
In this case, each
of those algorithms
does a very simple, stupid,
repetitively infinitely
powerful thing.
So on the far left, let's
pick a Vision example,
because I'm going
to show you a Vision
example in just a moment.
The idea here is, hey,
maybe this is a pixel.
And the pixel is black,
white, or something else.
It's black, white,
or something else
is all the algorithm can detect.
The algorithm next
to it might be
able to say, oh, for sure
it's black or it's white.
Another one can say, the
pixel is in this shade range
or this shade range.
You get the idea.
It's very, very simple.
The next layer would say, ah,
there's actually two pixels.
And spatially, they touch.
The third layer says, these
groups of pixels that touch,
these ones spatially
form a closed circuit.
The next layer might
decide if the closed
circuit is hollow or filled.
All the way at the end, you
can look at it and it'll say,
this is the number six.
I just gave you the Hello World
for machine learning, which
is called the MNIST workload.
So if you want to try a
sample on TensorFlow.org,
that's the one I would
start with is training out
your first MNIST
model that can detect
from very shaky handwritten, is
it 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 9?
That's literally what
your hello world is.
In this case, since we
have more than one layer
between the input layer
and the output layer,
this is called a deep
learning neural network.
Now you sound fancy.
If it didn't have any
layers in the middle,
it's called a neural network.
Are neural networks by
themselves worth anything?
Not so much there's not a lot
of applications for a two layer
network.
It turns out almost everything
needs multiple layers.
So if you're using neural
networks, you can be fancier
and just say, hey, I'm
using deep learning.
And people go, awesome.
Your company's worth 3x what
it was just a moment ago.
OK.
Shall I flip to a demo
since I've talked so much?
I will skip the setup on
cats, dogs, cars, and apples,
in the interest of time.
So everyone see this OK?
Star Trek moment.
You ready?
Ooh.
OK.
So what this is.
There's 80,000 images we
dragged off Creative Commons
and Wikimedia.
We grabbed Creative Commons
so Rob still has a job
and doesn't get
fired and doesn't
pay $3 million licensing
images for a two minute demo.
So each one of these we
ran through something
called Vision API.
And what Vision API
does is exactly what
I've just shown on the chart
with the neural network.
One side is raw
imagery of pixels.
The other right side, it
decides what those pixels
are based on confidence.
So some of the things
the models spit out
is, that's a cat, that's a dog,
that's a tree, that's a car.
And that's only interesting
if the model also tells you,
it's a cat, and we're
99% sure it's a cat.
In other words, we go
to meetings at work
not because we want to
hang out with our friends,
although that's
perfectly valuable.
That's what bars are for.
We go to meetings
so we can all agree
that the data is
sufficient enough
to make a decision against that
we're going to apply resources
for, and thus we defer risk.
So the whole idea
for a meeting is
that we establish a
confidence interval
that everyone finds sufficient.
Typically those aren't
mathematically relevant.
In this case, they are.
So on the far left, I've
saved some core imagery.
But each one of those images
that I ran through Vision API
is one of these.
Let me see.
If I'm particularly
careful, I can
scroll to where it will
actually render the image.
Each one of these dots is mapped
to a logical scientific method
namespace.
We remember this, right?
There's a null.
Then it's an animal,
vegetable, mineral.
If it's an animal, is it's
hot blooded, cold blooded?
Is it hot blooded, cold
blooded with fur, not fur?
Is it pretty, not pretty?
All those sorts of things
follow along the natural tree,
which is exactly how a
neural network does not work.
And I'll show you
that in just a moment.
So we think this way.
The neural network
doesn't think this way.
For those of you
that are actively
working on machine learning
and using deep science,
this is why your head hurts
and why most of the days
fall in failure.
Because you intuit why
the neural network does
a particular thing.
And that's OK because it doesn't
mind if you intuit or not.
It does not care.
It does what it does.
So let me flip right
over to the number one
denizen of the internet.
It turns out this is
our most popular image
type that we can scrape.
When we scrape the internet,
turns out the internet's
made out of cats.
Everyone heard
that the world sits
on the back of an elephant.
What's under the elephant?
It's elephants all the way down.
Turns out, no,
it's actually cats.
We can prove it.
In this case, this is what
the system Vision API labels
against this exact image.
We say it's a cat.
It's a pet, which is interesting
because that's a concept.
It's not a thing.
A pet implies ownership
and care and feeding.
But the system doesn't
mind that it's a concept.
This picture is a pet.
And we will largely go,
yep, that's obviously
not a wild animal.
Mammal, animal,
British shorthair.
Oh.
Now we're getting interesting.
All the way down to close up.
So now it's a meta
point about the fact
that the cat's head looks
relatively large, given
the focal distance, and there's
bokeh in the background, which
indicates it's probably
relatively close to the sensor
image.
So you get the idea that we
can do sensor-based images.
Let me call out one
quick thing on here.
Cat, 99% sure.
Vertebrate, 91% sure.
Wait, what?
Welcome to neural networks.
A couple of other points.
And I'll do as quickly
as the business value
so we can high five each
other at the end of this.
Anyone in the room not
seen a L'Oreal commercial?
Perfumes, pretty people,
everyone's fit, those things.
They're always in soft tones.
Everyone's kind of out of
focus and thus prettier.
That's what I tell myself.
But they spend a lot of time
managing their brand image
through color, look and
feel of their brand,
as represented both in
print ad and television.
Even radio, they always
pick a similar music chain
or a soft tone in the
person doing the over voice.
So they care very deeply,
because how in the world
do you sell perfume on TV?
Turns out they sell
a lot of perfume
based on TV commercials.
So what they do is they hire
an army of people in Photoshop
that make sure that all
the imagery they use
matches the color palette.
What if I could offer them
an internet scale system that
allows you to search
by color distribution
along a certain palette for
cats with soft hair that
are British shorthairs?
We just made $1 million, folks.
So you get the idea
that this drastically
changes the why you would
even do a particular workload
with similar or better
quality outputs against it.
Under the covers, this is
in a very advanced text
format called JSON.
It's just a REST call.
There's six lines of Python
code that it did that it
iterated through 80,687 times.
There was actually a little
bit more than 80,000.
Some of those images weren't
OK to show on screen.
And the reason I know that
if I flip back, you'll see I
have an inappropriate content
detection system inside
of this.
I can pick out medical
procedures, violent images,
spoofs, and the adult stuff.
I heard that's on the
internet somewhere.
So you guys get
the idea this can
serve as a massively
helpful way for you
to see how your brand
is being recognized,
where it's being posted
at, the color palette
on your competitors' products,
how they're being represented.
Does your brand appear
next to other brands
on internet at worldwide scale?
This is very, very
exciting stuff.
And people are doing this today.
Two more examples and I'll
jump out of this demo.
Australians?
Oi?
Do I have an oi?
Any other ois?
Oi, oi?
We don't get to three
oi's, we can't do the joke.
All right.
Two oi's it is.
This is a real-- by the
way, the transition,
we spent more time writing that
code for that cool little flip
than we did for the
machine learning part.
I spent weekends on that.
That was awesome.
This is a real sign.
Tree kangaroos are a thing,
and apparently they bite.
Let's not go to Australia.
Everything wants to kill you.
What I want to call
out here is it's
a sign, road sign, traffic sign.
So some poor computer scientist
and machine learning person
spent weeks of their
life figuring out
how to recognize signs
across all font types,
in poor lighting, with
rain on the camera lenses,
off internet things
that were off angle.
So there was a lot
of work went in.
So this is relatively
clean picture.
We have surprisingly
good efficiency
because the Maps
team has spent years
killing themselves
trying to figure out
from a lot of Priuses
with disco balls on top
driving all the roads.
Some of those frames
have really weird people
standing in front of
the lens doing this.
So they have to stitch
together the image behind it
to figure out what was on
that one included image.
And then they get to blur
the face of the idiot waving
at the camera.
So all of that work is built
into that one core system.
But we gain the benefits for
something with the Vision API.
The thing I want
to call out here
is not only are we
really, really sure
that this is a road sign--
94%, 90, 90.
So what I'm explaining
to you guys here
is I wouldn't just say, hey,
sign came back in the JSON.
It's a sign.
I would say, let's pull the
other four or five top labels.
And if those are congruent
in a language with being
roughly the same
entity, very, very sure
that Google is correct.
If I'm at 93% or
better, I haven't
seen us wrong from
a human measurement
point of view, meaning
yep, that's a cat, that's
a dog, that's a lion.
If it's 93% or better,
we're pretty good.
But actually, you can
make good business bets
on anything north of 75 or so.
But we're largely
wrong in some cases.
But when you add up
three 75's in a row,
eh, that gets to be pretty good.
So let me show something here.
We're grabbing all the text.
We do this for 103
languages, all font types.
We can convert between the two.
Color palette is here.
And I'll do one last one.
And this, in a way,
is the one I'm kind
of proudest of the team for.
Everyone, or most of us,
know that we're kind of close
to a baseball stadium
here in San Francisco.
It's AT&T Park.
It turns out that if we were
inside the baseball stadium,
we would largely use the same
language to describe verbally
what a baseball
stadium looks like.
There's this grass park.
It's kind of shaped
like a snow cone.
There's some dirt part.
And there's stands around it.
And there's a billboard in
the background with a score.
We largely use
the same verbiage.
What we've figured out here
is it's a stadium, team sport,
ballgame, baseball.
All that stuff is
perfectly fine.
Sports venue.
OK, we're genericizing
the case a little bit.
Multi-sport event,
because they picked out
that there's multiple lines.
And it's making a
guess that maybe you
can play football on this too.
So that's getting
pretty interesting.
The part I'm especially proud
of-- and it's not in the XF
data for the photo--
is what exact baseball
stadium in the world it is.
So we detect landmarks.
We do a pretty good job
detecting the Eiffel Tower
versus the Paris
Hotel in Las Vegas
versus a tricked out
picture of the Eiffel
Tower held in someone's hand.
We're not fooled, typically.
This is a case where,
without any lat/long,
we figured out what baseball
stadium in the world it was.
And it's Citi Field
where the Mets play.
It might be the only
chance any of us
ever see it because no one goes
to a Mets game, as we can see.
I'm here all week.
Let me flip back to the slides.
OK.
Slides are great.
We know that's not an apple.
It's for sure a cat.
This is the slide
where I indicate
that it doesn't come for free.
It's free like a baby,
not free like a prize.
So you get to care, you get
to feed, you get to maintain.
You retrain.
You operationalize.
You do worse than
a spreadsheet most
of the time for your
first set of models.
Later, you start
beating the spreadsheet.
You drop the mic
and you go home.
And then you start trying to
beat the simple models that
used to be in place
six months ago when
you told your boss that you
should do deep learning.
That is roughly
kind of the cycle.
So you have data that comes in.
You apply an
algorithm against it.
The algorithm probably
isn't the right one.
The data wasn't clean.
You don't have enough data.
I'm saying this is a whole
workload that you will turn
into something that you
operationalize the same way you
would saying, we
have a data team,
and they're pretty good
at doing data stuff.
You don't say we just
have database guys.
We have a data team.
Some people on the team
specialize in this.
Some people specialize in that.
When you start operationalizing
machine learning models
at scale in
production, you'll have
people that specialize
in your data cleansing.
You'll have some
algorithmic experts
that are really good
at soft edge detection
systems versus hard
edge detection systems.
And yes, those are different
ends of the math branch.
And then you'll discover over
time that some of these things,
you know what, we don't need
to stay on the cutting edge.
We're just going to use
someone else's black box
ones like Google's because
they're good enough.
And we want to write the
specialized one where we have
unique IP to lend against it.
Does this make sense?
Not for free.
Baby, not prize.
This is the horrifying slide
that has everyone going, man,
that's awful.
This literally is what
our marketing team
gets paid to create.
I do the names,
they do the logos.
So the far right
bar are our names.
So guess who's overpaid?
C'est moi.
Machine Learning
Engine is the engine
that you use to create machine
learning models and training
systems.
Our translation service
is called Translation.
Our vision system
is called Vision.
You get it.
So we try to stay
pretty functional named.
If you can read
the hieroglyphics,
this is a great bar
game for itself.
The part I'll call
out are naturally
connected with each other.
Oops.
I broke the internet.
Are these two layers.
So things on the
data side, of course,
are naturally related to
the machine learning side.
We're getting a lot
of free attention
in this room and other
rooms around machine
learning because
it's new science
and it's unicorns and glitter.
It's all magic at this point.
No data, no quality
data, no machine data,
no coalesced data out of
19 different databases
into a single data store,
no machine learning.
I have no solution for anyone
in this room if you say,
but a lot of my
transactional data
is in my Oracle
financial system.
But my online system is
in my e-commerce system,
which is hosted somewhere else.
But don't worry.
All my logging data which I want
to combine into my learnings
as well sits on my Apache
servers, which is at my hoster.
Let's do some machine learning.
And I'll say, come back to
me when you have big data.
So the only thing I
can leave a lot of you
guys with if you don't have some
sort of big data system figured
out is go get some big
data systems figured out.
We have a pretty
good one in BigQuery
that does a lot of
things with data flow,
data lab, other things with
words "big" and "data" in them
other than Spanner.
And that was just
too cool to change.
You guys get the idea.
This is one of the
things that Google
does at super large scale.
The reason we have the red
column, Machine Learning,
is because we had the data.
We don't assume that
everyone in this room
is going to start ingesting
a petabyte of data a week,
exabyte of data a year.
That's not a
reasonable assumption.
What we can say is
the systems that we
use to train against a 10
gigabyte data size should
execute in a non-batch
UI, meaning I literally
will run a job and I won't
grab that cup of coffee.
We've all had the
compiler day, right?
Today's the day I'm going
to build some stuff.
You compile.
If it's non-trivial,
you'll go get a coffee
or you go have some lunch.
You come back and you
look at all the warnings
and bugs, right?
That's the nature
of the reality.
But what if you could
just compile on the fly
or always be compiling?
In this case, what if you
could always be training?
Or, visually to you,
the fractional unit
of time of training always in
the background as data changes,
or as you do shifts on how
you're cleaning the data,
if it's always up to speed,
you never have to take a break.
You spend so much
more time iterating
on the math and the
algorithm choices,
it moves you from a
seven month cycle,
on average, for a good
model, to seven days.
Seven months to seven days.
And how do we do that?
Let's talk about that.
OK.
Customers have this problem.
We have this problem
when we are a customer.
I need data access
in a lot of places.
I need to develop,
build analytical models.
A lot of these things are
kind of non-negotiable.
We'll all nod our heads.
These are the surface area that
we're trying to apply product
to rather than just process to.
Today, largely, everybody
solves these things in process
if you're doing
machine learning.
We'd like this to be
productized so you
spend all your time doing
other, more interesting things.
Because, again, 75% of
the machine learner's time
is spent playing with data.
None of that time
is time they want.
And for many people, that's
because they're already
on BigQuery.
For the people that aren't
using a big data system which
is a fully managed
service, they spend a lot
of their time
provisioning servers,
misrouting networking,
misconfiguring CPU choices,
not understanding the fact
that they lose those boxes
at the end of the week because
those virtual machines get
reprovisioned by their CTO.
You get the idea that
having these things fungibly
available is actually part of
the magic for how we don't have
to say there's features here.
It's implied.
Why in the world
would you write things
that do this if these things
were just automated for you?
And this is a little
bit of my eye chart.
I'm happy to give the
slides after this.
I think we ship out
the slides next week.
For those of you with any
particularly large screen,
it's fun to watch people
take pictures with those.
If you've got an iPad, please
hold those up and take photos.
Those are fun.
In this case, these are the
overall vertical systems
that we're focused on.
Each one of those
areas which right now
are gray, I aspire
to have a blue link--
case studies, examples, partner
lists, and model marketplaces
that support these.
So let me pick one
at reasonable random.
Let's do financial services
because money is always fun.
Sales and marketing
campaign management
and financial services.
That's an odd one.
So what if I wanted to
understand, what is the percent
rate that I should
publish on my website
to gain high creditworthy
people, West Coast US only,
and I want people
under the age of 50?
That sounds like a pretty
straightforward ad campaign,
right?
But what if I had some
modeling data that
was available from each
individual cookie on the system
that was [INAUDIBLE]
clean, so none of that data
is in the cookie.
But I can infer it based
on a pattern of behavior
by the sites they've
gone to before,
the sites they go to after
me, what part of my website
they look at, how long
they linger per page.
That's a straight
up classification
or recommendation problem.
People do that at scale today.
So if I had a simple enough
experience around that,
we would all shift from
a heuristic-based system
to machine learning system.
It's just frankly better.
But the complexity
involved means
that only the people that
specialize in this stuff
would do it.
So the people that build
recommendations for living,
or the people in
the retail space
that do this, or
e-commerce people
will make this a very
dark set of magic
because that's one of
their core competencies.
There's no reason it
has to be that way.
And we're going to post papers
and release core models.
Let everybody do this stuff.
But we're going to give
the science behind how
you get the data ready for it.
Each one of these will
be a similar effort.
It'll take us a
while to bite at it.
And one of the questions I get
pretty commonly at this point
is, which ones are
you going to focus on?
And I'm going to give
you a cloud answer.
You ready for a cloud answer?
All of them.
You don't or in the cloud,
if you're in the cloud game.
If you're a platform, you need
sufficiency on all the areas.
Some may come a little
bit sooner than others
because they might be
simpler on the science side
or on the sales side.
But we intend to try to
go for the full space.
Hopefully that's helpful.
And I've broken
the internet again.
So this is the last interesting
slide, but I have more.
Don't worry.
I'll try to put
this onto a spectrum
so you guys kind of get the
idea on why we do what we do.
Because why is always more
interesting than what.
What changes so often.
In this case, TensorFlow
on the far left.
Very, very powerful,
pretty flexible.
It is, I think, 4x
adopted in Kaggle
versus other deep learning
frameworks at this point.
I can say that because
we've now closed on Kaggle.
That's exciting.
Welcome to Google, Kaggle folks.
Super, super fun guys.
In this space,
TensorFlow is largely
meant to advance the science.
But it also, in many
cases, is completely
sufficient for production use.
It is the foundational
layer that we're
using to create the services
further to the right.
So not only would it be
an area that you would
apply research and core R&D on.
That's what we
are doing as well.
So as we learn things
that TensorFlow
needs or should have,
we write those things
and contribute those things.
We absolutely encourage
you to do the same.
And the middle section,
it's Cloud ML Engine.
We went through a rename.
This basically automates the
sucky bits of TensorFlow.
I need 64 GPUs.
I need 12 of these in the US.
I need 14 in Asia.
I need the following
SSD IOs per second.
I need it for 17
minutes probably,
but it could be three
hours because I'm using
convolutional neural networks.
I have no idea how long
this stuff is going to take.
The model itself signals itself
it wants to be retrained.
Boy oh boy, how do
you do that stuff?
Well, the answer is have someone
else do the hard science.
So we're largely there for
version one kind of capability
that allows you to t-shirt
size your environment.
I want small, medium, large.
I want it eventually, or
it's a trivial problem.
Or it's a reasonable problem
and I want it reasonably quickly
and I'm willing to pay for it.
Or I really freaking
want it now and I don't
care how hard the problem is.
And then there's custom after
that that you call Rob for.
So behind each one of
those, currently we're
templating out the hardware
required based on the model
choice and the data shape that
we're detecting and forming
our own belief system around.
In the future, we'll
arbitrage all of that away.
You'll just say, I would
like an answer in an hour.
And we'll say an hour,
will cost you $3.
You'll say, actually,
two hours is fine.
OK, two hours is $0.32.
Based on your business, now
you can start doing predictions
on what it's going to cost you
to train or run predictions
at scale for your system.
That's where we're
going this is systems
built on top of systems,
elephants all the way down.
So on the far right side,
this is the black box area.
And I will have
solutions for you guys
that I can't talk about non-NDA.
But follow this space over
the next coming months.
We'll have a solution
that slots in between I
want to train my own thing
but I want it to be automated,
or Google does
everything for me.
Like, what if we don't label
a particular kind of couch
as this is French Renaissance?
And you're like, boy, I'm
running a furniture antique
site.
I really want it to label
accurately to that level.
We would label
couch, divan, purple.
We're even getting to the area
of human measurement-based
labeling.
It's pretty.
It's comfortable.
The room is bright.
There's a good view.
You can guess who I'm
talking with-- hotels, right?
So those kind of
people want to label,
as people do reviews
of their site,
why can't they then
say, as you can see,
we have 74 people that said
the room was bright and airy,
rather than having humans do it.
So this is the case where I want
to add that capability myself,
but I don't want to have seven
million images of couches
to do it.
Maybe I only have
a few thousand.
We have some science
here that's going
to help us be able to do that.
And you'll be able
to either control
whether you want that
data to be public,
meaning everyone can
run predictions on that,
and thus you have a model
that you own or sell.
Or you want it to be available
only for your own systems.
So this is our current
gamut of experience.
Pause on this one.
Everyone can read.
I'll look for a firm
nod and a sip of beer.
Firm nods, sipping beers.
OK.
I did video already.
Let me flip back to this.
How are we on time?
I will call this
the last demo I do.
United States Congress.
This is a natural language demo.
So what this does is you
type in a search query.
It will return the
Wikipedia article.
It'll apply natural language
against the entirety
of the article, identify
all the entities,
like what are the subjects
of each individual sentence
or the paragraph intent?
Was it positive or
negative in sentiment?
And then what was the
sentence construction?
So we'll do full syntactical
analysis for you on the fly.
So in this case, you'll
see a lot of underlining.
So if I just highlight
"US Congress,"
you can see that we're picking
up the fact that legislature is
the same entity as US Congress.
Congress is the same
thing as Congress.
Kind of makes sense.
We also highlight the
important entities
on the side and relative matrix.
This demo will blow a
weekend really fast.
So let's do US House
of Representatives.
So I click on the entity.
What we're going to do here
is the next logical step.
What are the entities
related to this entity?
There goes Sunday.
So you can follow it all
the way through the system.
But when you look at relatively
well-constructed articles,
you can start figuring out
where the articles are biased.
And if you were to pull up
Donald Trump's, he's a guy.
I hear he's the president.
You'll figure out that not
everyone cares about Donald
Trump because his
Wikipedia article, which
is meant to be down the
middle of the fairway,
is relatively negative.
Congress, by the way,
is slightly positive.
You know the major contributor
to the US Congress article?
Aides from the US Congress.
Know your data, folks.
OK.
I said last one.
We can go long.
There's no one coming after me.
The crew is-- no,
we can't go long.
OK.
So let me quickly show this one,
and then I can take questions.
Car lots.
I need to sell cars.
Where is my demo?
So what we have here is somebody
wanted to write an image
detection service so when you
go to a car auction in Japan,
you buy the car
basically sight undriven.
Just you get to see
it on the screen.
You bid on it.
You get the car.
But from the photos
from the car,
it's so competitive in
the used car space there,
they want to take the
photos, directly ship it back
to the business backside.
And it'll self-identify
what model of vehicle is
and what they should
have paid for it.
So in this case, they
created a simple web page.
I have the exact
imagery here from one
of the guys that goes to the
auction that take the pictures.
We drag, drop directly
on the screen.
It ingests those
images as we go.
They have a
self-classification model
that they've written to
identify vehicle types from all
the imagery.
This takes about 45 seconds.
Let me cut right
to Betty Crocker.
You guys can see that
they're 89% sure that they
should have paid between
$39,000 and $43,000.
And it's very, very likely
it's a 2012 Toyota Land Cruiser
Prado edition.
Prado's not offered in the US.
It's Asian market only.
So you get the idea
that you can see,
per individual image, which
ones they had images of.
And not only does it
identify what the vehicle is.
It's identified that the
guy who went to the auction
did a really bad job.
They're missing photos.
They can't do the listing
without all the photos
being present.
Go back to the vehicle
you just bought
and take the rearview
camera version of the photo.
Take the one for
side rear emblem.
Those are missing from the site.
They're not allowed to list
it without all these images
are being present.
Kind of cool.
This is a car
company in Japan that
did this in about two months.
OK.
So let me try to fulfill my
promise of moving to the end
as fast as I can.
No one cares about
related sessions.
I'll leave the summary up.
And then I'll stop here.
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]